that's emailed to me was I want you to
give yourself some Grace fall in love
with the real Savannah Todd Chrisley
still on Dad Duty Behind Bars comforting
daughter Savannah with words of wisdom
last week was
the toughest week I think of my life and
it's been hard Savannah opens up on her
unlocked podcast taped one week after
her dad and mom Julie Chrisley
surrendered to prison the day that
we dropped my parents off you know that
was that was really tough like just
saying goodbye to them
from home and knowing that
that was the last time for
God only knows how long my dad's fight
absolute best friend and I don't just
get to pick up the phone and call them
any family who faces a loved one going
to prison it's a very difficult
challenge that's true for this family
but they're strong they're faithful and
I think they'll continue in in that Way
Forward they're the two most giving
people I think I've ever met my entire
life and that giving continues just now
it's all over email and that's emailed
to me was
good morning my beauty how did you sleep
I want you to give yourself some Grace
fall in love with the real Savannah the
one that I raise that radiates a room
with her kindness and compassion not the
one the world wants to see remember
to gain the world and lose your soul
then what do you have what we will not
do is we will not break this comes after
E.T confirmed Todd's oldest daughter
Lindsay along with Mother Nanny Faye
visited him at his Florida prison I did
a little road trip this weekend
with my nanny my family struggled
through a lot with my parents this year
um there was just like so many things
that happened legally those legal things
Todd and Julie's convictions for bank
fraud and tax evasion which led to their
combined 19-year prison sentence take
all the money away take I don't
give a crap about any of that take it
all away if I can just have my parents
back that's like that's literally all
that matters we find strength in knowing
that there is fight
that there are other there's a plan of
action in place
so for that I'm grateful well I think
they're optimistic and let me be clear I
think that optimism is well placed this
trial was riddled with heirs and we
expect the appeals court to see that and
now Savannah's figuring out her new
normal in the aftermath seeing my
parents this past weekend definitely
gave me a sense of hope and peace and
it's weird it's weird to say oh going to
you know a prison camp that gave me
peace it was such an overwhelming
feeling
and who would have ever thought I've
never seen two people my parents be so
steadfast in their faith in the end the
truth will prevail may get harder before
it gets easier but we have faith
[Music]